welcome to the world of digital
marketing in 2024 digital marketing is
all about promoting products and
services using the internet and digital
channels it's an everchanging field that
helps businesses reach their customers
and achieve their marketing goals in
2024 there are few important Trends to
keep in mind First artificial
intelligence and machine learning are
playing a big role these technology
helps businesses personalize their
marketing efforts and provide better
customer experiences video content is
also becoming more popular platforms
like YouTube and Tik Tok are great for
businesses to engage with their audience
and showcase their products or Services
social media is still a big part of
digital marketing platforms like
Facebook and Instagram allow businesses
to connect with their customers and
build brand awareness influencer
marketing is also on the rise where
businesses collaborate with popular
social media users to promote their
products digital marketing is not just a
tool for promotion it's a way to build
meaningful relationship with customers
and adapt to the changing digital
landscape so in this video on digital
marketing road map 2024 we will learn
about digital marketing and its s
structure we will also understand the
step-by-step road map in which we will
be covering the learning path to become
a digital marketing professional but
before we begin let me ask you a quick
question question so what does ROI stand
for in digital marketing option A is
return on investment option b is reach
of Impressions option C is revenue on
investment and option D is rate of
interaction now you can pause this video
and answer in the comment section below
all right so let's start with the topic
which is digital marketing professional
salary so the salary of a digital
marketing professional can vary
depending on factors such as experience
location industry and the size of the
company in general digital marketing
professionals can earn a competitive
salary for an entry level position or
those with less experience the average
salary can range from $40,000 to $60,000
per year as professionals gain more
experience and expertise in the field
their salaries can increase
significantly mid-level digital
marketing professional with few ways of
experience can expect to earn between
$60,000 to $90,000 per year whereas
senior level digital marketing
professional with an extensive
experience and proven ta record of
success can earn salaries upwards to
$100,000 all right so this was about
digital marketing and digital marketing
salary now let's move on and understand
the digital marketing road map for 2024
so here are the basic steps and learning
path if you're looking to become a
successful digital marketer first is
learn the essentials of digital
marketing digital marketing is a broad
term that encompasses various techniques
and methods methods used to promote
websites or products online it is not a
single discipline but rather a
collection of strategies that businesses
can employ to reach their target
audience these strategies include search
engine optimization social media
marketing content marketing email
marketing and more by utilizing these
techniques businesses can increase their
online visibility attract more website
visitors and ultimately Drive
conversions and sales digital marketing
is essential in today's digital age as
it allows businesses to to effectively
connect with their audience and achieve
their marketing goals next is
understanding seo seo or search Eng and
optimization is a crucial aspect of
digital marketing it involves optimizing
a website to improve its visibility and
ranking on search engine results pages
to master SEO one must focus on keyword
research and onpage optimization
techniques this involves identifying
relevant keywords and incorporating them
strategically into the website content
additionally understanding link building
and backlink analysis is important for
building authority and credibility
technical SEO knowledge is also
necessary including optimizing website
speed and ensuring well structured site
by mastering YouTube SEO Google SEO
local SEO Etc businesses can enhance
their online presence and attract
organic traffic from search engines so
if you are interested in advancing your
career consider Purdue University's
postgraduate program in digital
marketing this comprehensive program
offers certification as a digital
marketer through live Interactive
Learning dive deep into fundamental and
advanced digital marketing strategies
utilizing Harvard Business publishing
cases and Hands-On participation in 20
plus projects access the full spectrum
of digital marketing tools with Chad GPD
and AI tools complemented by 35 Plus
dedicated resources all right now moving
on to the next one that is PPC
advertising PPC advertising or payer
click advertising a powerful digital
marketing strategy that allows you to
create an oversee campaigns on platforms
like Google ads and Bing ads this
skillful approach involves keyword Bing
where you choose the words or phrases
for which your ads will appear you must
learn ad targeting ensuring your ads
reach the Right audience Etc crafting
compelling ad copies is another
essential aspect as it entices potential
customers to click monitoring campaign
performance is crucial enabling you to
tweak and optimize for better results
all right so this was about PPC
advertising coming to the next one which
is learn social media marketing social
media marketing is a crucial aspect of
promoting website effectively depending
on the nature of the websites it is
essential to explore various social
media networks such as Twitter Pinterest
or LinkedIn each platform offers unique
opportunities to engage with different
Target audiences and expand brand
visibility to succeed in social media
marketing one must possesses the
necessary skills to create and compel
content engage with users and analyze
data to optimize strategies so this was
about social media marketing all right
coming to the next one which is conduct
content marketing campaigns learning how
to conduct marketing campaigns is a
crucial skill for aspiring digital
marketers it involves identifying target
audience creating diverse content
strategies and maintaining consistency
in content delivery monitoring key
metrics like website traffic and
engagement traes is a vital for success
by mastering these skills individuals
can excel in the dynamic field of
digital marketing adapting strategies
based on the audience behavior and Data
Insights gaining Proficiency in campaign
management is a fundamental step towards
becoming a successful digital marketer
all right now coming to the next step to
become a digital marketer which is
knowledge of email marketing email
marketing is a powerful strategy for
businesses to engage with their Audience
by learning how to build effective email
marketing campaigns you can create
compelling content that resonates with
your subscribers understanding email
Automation and segmentations allows you
to send targeted messages based on
customer preferences and behavior
utilizing email marketing platforms and
tools streamlines the process and helps
you track campaign performance all right
so this was about the knowledge of email
marketing now the next step for the
learning part to become a digital
marketer is to learn data analysis and
Reporting tools data analysis and
Reporting tools are essential for
digital marketers to make informed
decisions and optimize their campaigns
some popular tools include Google
analytics which provides detailed
insights into website traffic and user
behavior and Google data Studio which
allows marketers to create visually
appealing reports and dashboards other
tools like SC rush and Moos help with
keyword research and competitor analysis
these tools enable marketers to track
key metrics identify Trends and measure
the success of their digital marketing
efforts ultimately leading to more
effective strategies and improved Roi so
this was about data analysis and
Reporting tools now coming to the next
step which is be updated with the latest
trends so the digital marketing industry
is constantly evolving which changes
happening on a daily basis this makes it
an exciting and challenging profession
as experts must cont continuously learn
and adapt the dynamic nature of digital
marketing ensures that professionals
never get bored as there are always new
strategies Technologies and Trends to
explore staying updated is crucial to
success in this field as it allows
marketers to leverage the latest tools
and techniques to reach their target
audience effectively so this was about
getting or being updated now coming to
the last step which is start looking for
opportunities to Kickstart a career in
digital marketing it's crucial to build
a strong portfolio and resume start by
showcasing your skills and expertise in
various digital marketing areas such as
social media management content creation
SEO and analytics include any relevant
projects campaigns or certifications you
have completed once your portfolio is
ready begin searching for jobs that
align with your interest and goals
tailor your resum to highlight your
relevant experience and skills and don't
forget to network and leverage online
platform forms to increase your chances
of Landing for your dream job so this
was about the road map that you can
follow if you're interested and want to
become a digital marketing professional
in 2024 by mastering these skills
earning certifications and gaining
hands-on experience you are equipping
yourself with the tools needed to thrive
in this Dynamic field all right guys
with that we have come to the end of
this video If you like this video please
give it a thumbs up I hope it really
help you all thanks for watching stay
safe safe and keep learning staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing do
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here